and so i do a lot of work and i know i
know you do a lot of work and i know
like i just saw this article come up on
twitter today and it was i guess
it was that whole gilmore girls thing
where you're out with your buddies one
night and you're partying and uh for
some reason uh lauren uh from gilmore
graham got sick they had to switch
scenes around and so
paint that picture exactly what happened
because this kind of got your work ethic
to where it is now in a way right yeah
literally it was it was sort of like one
of these one of these situations where
on kilmer girls i think i was number 12
or 15 or something on the call depending
on uh whether it was season one or five
uh or anything between um and i think i
was filming like just as an example and
i remember the exact details but i
wasn't filming for several more days
um and then
we all stayed up and it was pretty
i was gonna say like we were we were
you know
having a crazy time it was like me and
my my buddies like playing grand theft
auto that are just coming out and i had
one of those big ol i think like one of
the first things i bought in gimbal
girls was one of those giant tvs that
weighs as much as the car
and takes up a giant amount of space for
those people who were born before 2000
they used to be giant and it was like
plasma
ps3 or ps2 or ps1 whatever it was and we
had grand theft auto and so we'd sit
there and play i had like my puppy and
this meant
uh and so we had stayed up like
playing games ordering papa john's
uh
and probably like drinking coors light
or some redneck stuff it was like a lot
of texans also um
and so then we went to bed around
whatever time
didn't didn't go nuts we weren't like
drinking booze like taking whiskey shots
right but we're just like drinking beer
and staying up late um and then i had a
puppy at the time
sadie city girl who who passed away and
koda who you met last time uh he had
surgery so he's not here right now
otherwise i bring him in for a cameo
so
like went to bed and i had gone to home
depot and bought like
plywood and
sod and uh turf and i made this like
four by two my daddy and i had made this
four by two like little p place for
sadie to go to the bathroom on my
balcony because i lived on the third
floor
of uh
4301 fulton for
i don't live there anymore uh but 4301
fulton so it was like two blocks up from
uh casa vega right right
right on the little exactly where that
is yep yeah and my neighbor uh
yeah anyways and you're close to work by
the way that's relatively 10 minutes
away from work dude i was down riverside
or or moore park yeah it was right there
right it was 50 minutes in l.a
um and so i had left the the screen door
open to the balcony going like okay she
kind of knew and there's like some spray
that smells like
urine i guess uh but you spray it where
you want your dog to pee so like if you
live in an apartment in new york or l.a
or san francisco then they're like well
this is like the thing that you can do
to make your dog pee here because they
smell urine they want to pee i guess
this is kind of disgusting sorry it's uh
it's educational
so
so i had that stuff and like sprayed it
and i was like okay i'll leave this i'll
leave this uh door open
and then all of a sudden i'm woken up at
like eight in the morning my buddy
jordan uh what's up jordan uh who's one
of my dear friends stood in my wedding
and he's like hey man they need you on
set and i was like this isn't a funny
joke like well leave me alone you know
like
turning over the pillow
and he's like no no they like uh spilo
called me who's my my manager produce
partner
uh dance pillow and
he's like no they they've been calling
and i was like what are you talking
about i got my phone which is probably
like a
not even a motorola razor it would have
been whatever the little small phones
were right nokia yeah
nokia probably nokia nokia nokia
no nokia he says and i had a bunch of
missed calls and voicemails and texts
right and i was like oh jesus
and so i get up and then i find out the
story but you know it's time you're 20
and so a cold shower and a cup of coffee
you're like all right were you running a
marathon or what but it was the worst
feeling it was like the the
the classic like negative school uh
trope or whatever right where it's just
and i was like i never want to be there
again um
and i uh you just felt like you're not
prepared you you know you you kind of
lost you're on set you're kind of like
it just was really uncomfortable for you
it was more than uncomfortable man like
it was it was
scarring frankly like like ptsd not like
legit ptsd but it was like it stays with
me to this day
what was it was it embarrassing because
you didn't know your lines or
no man like
everybody on set was kind and gracious
and
they knew me and i knew i could do a
good enough job i suppose um not really
being prepared but i just felt like i
was being an [ __ ] like i felt like i
was
as nice as ever as being
i felt like they must hate my guts like
here i am some 19 year old kid
showing up probably smelled like coors
light
um and
they have family i didn't have family
you know like well i had family i have
kids or something right right
but i just felt like
man i
like these people's
time is valuable